it's the fighter and the kid had to run
it back cause we back at it again yeah
we gon keep it moving like it's never
gonna end when it was brendan when it
was brian when he was just talking to
friends we got the kid calling on the
left with the fighter on the right had
to do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is really the fighter and the kid
we're out come on baby
chin is this is how we do it
don't go chin that's looking juicy i
know and it goes well with his [ __ ]
black capezio dance slacks and his
awesome
shirt dude you look like a jazz dancer
from the 90s in the best way and i mean
it you actually look really good
chin i think you should do the neck
look at chin's body looking at you i was
looking at cheat over i'd love to do the
neck you'd probably frown a pound and uh
stand up and want to do it
the longest time yeah
is uh chin is [ __ ] um
mark teaching you some tricks are you
out picking his brother i definitely
picked his brain a few times yeah he's
definitely i like that there's a little
rumor that good old bry
has
heard there's some chatter online that
good old bry
is on the trt
really yeah now which form is that not
the one i'm reading i was gonna say the
the the subreddit i'm reading saying
different well i'm just saying that i i
if it is true i really appreciate that
it means that i did your girl say this
one guy told me all right one guy told
me and said there's some talk about
whether you're natty or not it's one guy
you probably met him right he's trying
to impress you so you that was his way i
was really happy i was like maybe i look
muscular enough
yeah
daddy's i'm fresh off the plane from
portland brian tell me about portland
now now let me ask you this important
and this might be i'm going to they
burned it down
this way i said in my bed about portland
i said portland is uh i go uh you know i
talk about all the cities i've been like
yeah i like portland i'm staying
downtown sure i take a beat i go a
little dicey i know it's basically
gotham city but when bane took over
uh-huh like it is
intense dude
i hate the cops what the cops do is they
found the police okay we'll just take a
seat but we had a cop come to the show
not not in uniform he's just a fan and
he comes to the show and he he does the
meet and greet
and i meet him big guy whatever we're
talking and i go yeah tough being a cop
around here man i want to fun you guys
yeah he goes anyway uh he didn't want to
get into it anyway um are you guys going
out and i go i don't really go out man
and he goes you're staying around here i
go yeah near voodoo donut shows yep
that's my
that's where i patrol don't go out now
you're what he goes don't go out now why
won't i guys oh i don't know and i was
like
voodoo donuts i love voodoo i love that
area we've been there many times cat
club's right there i go voodoo donuts is
dangerous he goes yeah he goes have you
ever seen a donut store with a security
guard before i know he goes there's a
reason that guy's there he was in that
same area we've had 22 shootings in the
past week dude oh what yeah what
22 shooting two because omaha nebraska
apparently so nomads really nice the old
marketplace when the sun come down about
9 00 p.m
we went into this place called eat the
worm terrible mexican food a shot
well it's called eat the word they had
to throw the they had to throw the
toilet bowl all of us kevin mac all my
everybody just [ __ ] your pants it was
the crazy [ __ ] but
the
when you get in there there are two
security guards two cops i'm sorry with
guns here they have the bulletproof vest
and their gun is here and i was like
it's a little over overkill and he goes
not anymore not anymore we're always
ready you never know who's going to be a
shooter i was like holy [ __ ] crap yep
and then my same energy at the schools
yeah my buddy who's a bodybuilder who
who's great uh who opens uh for me nick
simmons uh funny as [ __ ] he's a
bodybuilder fake his [ __ ] yup thinking
[ __ ] funny as [ __ ] from brooklyn
and the two security guards black guys
were jacked out of their minds turns out
they were bodybuilders and they got a
new the first question was the guy goes
there he is there he is funny as [ __ ]
and thick as [ __ ] vicky a thicky funny
and they but what's the question first
question guy goes well gear you running
i started talking gear it was [ __ ]
great now by the builders you mean guys
that work out right because they're not
making money bodybuilding no he's not
he's he's not no he's not a person yeah
so don't say about it but he's studying
exercise physiology has his degree in
college and uh funny dude dude funny
funny he keeps saying that uh new york
funny [ __ ]
and uh it's a little dude how about i
was supposed to be in san francisco this
weekend i get a call last week from uh
the club
and they go hey dude we should
reschedule and i go why i know it's very
rare i reschedule like it's it's the
summer a but b the district the d.a got
recalled and he's like you thought crime
was bad before people aren't going out
like our restaurants are dead what and
we knew something was up because jay you
know who my road manager called me goes
something's going on there man because
you know i always like to stay in nice
hotels if i can't airbnb and jay's like
like the nice hotels like eighty dollars
a night what yeah because i like set
four seasons whatever yeah that's eighty
dollars he's like this ain't good i'm
like man what's going on maybe it's just
people are going to san francisco or
something like that and then calls like
the the crime is no point how about that
chesa boudin gets recalled so we pushed
yeah we had to push today that's what
happened think about what they have
taken that city one of the greatest
cities in america and destroyed it i
love that la went ah we like what
garcon's doing up there come down here
yeah and then nuts yeah well he'll get
recalled too at least oh yeah he'll get
recovered yeah because the one thing
that everybody like the one the great
equalizer votes on safety the great
equalizer i don't care what your
position is left middle you can talk all
you want conservative gender all that
stuff but as soon as safety is
compromised even the woman are like kids
and defenses especially them
i love biden's like i never said that
like
yeah he did yeah wow seeing a different
two now my man people that that's
because he's the biggest political
liability oh people want to say he did
yeah
yeah that's right it's san fran that
that's that was a city dude what a great
city what a [ __ ] great scene i'm so
disappointed i supposed to be the
[ __ ] friday and saturday
what a bummer the cheapest hotel is 80
bucks 80 bucks whoo ace hotel was 60
bucks a year well what have you seen
what was that thing where if you want to
get a a u-haul from san fran to idaho it
costs you you know 500
and they'll pay you to take it back or
something like that really yeah like if
you want to take a u-haul to san
francisco it's like you know well what
that do i forget what that uh
politician said is a great quote they're
asking about gas price inflation he's
some republican uh
politician he's like i mean it'd be
cheaper to do cocaine and run to the
cities than drive with these gas prices
and he's like an older guy i think it
was mitch whatever mitch mcconnell yeah
he was like you'd be cheaper just do a
bunch of cocaine and jog
this old man i think well that's a great
joke sir wow that's a pretty good yeah
it's so funny well no one laughed it ate
[ __ ] but i found it hilarious what's it
cost you to fill that tank your tank on
your phone uh fry that mark just dented
uh good question it would be uh about
150 bucks mark gave him a little thing
mark daniel ferrari you know mark mark's
a wild man he's a wild man yeah he can't
be in the ferrari anymore but well
sometimes his muscles are so sharp
mm-hmm just hit that
well my son does that my son will just
go gang oh no no the day i got my my
tesla the day and still tesla
he just opens my my girl's car just goes
shoom and it just goes
dink kids don't care kid i mean like 38
we gotta know our surroundings a little
bit yeah i mean you can't have another
car anymore well that to be fair hang it
up very long and heavy door
long and heavy door i don't care no i
don't i don't care if it's the longest
journal yeah i've never done that ever
in my life though right i understand
yeah that that's a that's that's i you
have a lot of balls driving that thing
because if i don't because i've never
dented a car or it's got a wheel or not
even a defender better with that it can
really [ __ ] with the value of that
knockdown would yeah but yeah no little
scratch you had to drop uh boston off
someone he's two and i argued not to do
this yeah he's in uh summer camp yeah
he's two yeah brian he's never been on
his own
this summer camp is from 8 30 a.m to 2
30 p.m it's a long long time and they
bring like their nap so they can nap i'm
like he's not he don't know these fools
this kid ain't napping in this weird-ass
place he's two he's two we dropped him
off this morning i have the worst
anxiety now joe's right up the street in
case he freaks out to pick him up but
yeah it's a lot man that's a that's a i
told his mom you know i'm like i don't
agree with this man he should be half
day yeah like even kindergarten another
kid wasn't that long it's a long time i
mean too long now he was crying to play
with other kids and stuff like that but
after about the first initial hour he's
been like all right where the hell are
my parents yeah i knew my son marched to
a different drum because when my son was
in preschool
and in kindergarten well he would take
his nap
when he wanted yeah everybody had a nap
and he'd be like oh i'm definitely not
napping here but what i'm gonna do is
i'm gonna nap at
right before school's over i'm gonna
take a little shout out
very european of him well very european
took a little siesta and then i realized
he also marched to a different drum like
his dad like his dad there was a musical
for all the kindergartners a little
musical and i'm watching the musical but
my son well he ain't anywhere to be
found in fact what he was doing was
running behind the curtain and then
coming out and going
and just messing around not being a
nuisance being a newbie general nuisance
being in line i look to the teacher i go
he's uh
kind of an outsider and she goes he's
always been that way i go well
all right well hopefully they get in
line he's got a crystal clear sense of
humor so he'll be a comic we'll see
him on the outside look at it yeah you
never know
yeah we'll see how bosti does today man
you know i didn't agree with it are they
similar in personality boston tiger very
different right yeah very different yeah
and tigers he's he's so much bigger but
he'll just let boston abuse him like
dude don't let him [ __ ] yank on your
eyes
like if [ __ ] get him off you dude
yeah he's like so gentle with him yep
you know i went to the omaha zoo i don't
know if he told you number three in the
world so there's nothing to do no more
number three start going to the zoo hold
on there's the bob carey pedestrian
bridge and a cop told me not to go there
because of the gangs so i didn't on the
bridge
yeah the gang's hanging on the bridge
uh the gangs hang on the bridge
and uh and that three whites yeah yeah
three whites three whites and i'm
singing a song there and everything else
so uh we went there and and that's the
number three zoo in the world and still
more same zoo you know zoos are for kids
they're just for kids i mean dude three
grown men are do you guys molest kids no
three no but they shot me they we shot
some content [ __ ] around i went back
on the zoo it was fun that was about it
would be cool if you like get behind the
scenes like play with the tigers and
[ __ ] well we could have done that but i
found that out about that afterwards and
also i've done that before
you know what i mean i'm right at the
zeus now i'm not watching that you know
what i'm saying yeah yeah unless it's
brian jump into the tiger exhibit yep
now now see that's content that's a good
time you want likes or not you want subs
dad yep you want subs dad yeah you're
right let's go and jump into the polar
bear exhibit well micho
drops the second episode drops today
hunting pythons catching some stuff
it'll be fun it's interesting it's
actually a very good one yeah i'm proud
of it fun yeah we had to win where's oh
louis ck i don't want to ruin his joke i
think he's his new material but he talks
about how you only go to the zoo when
you're in other cities like he has a
comic you only go to zoos when in other
cities yeah he goes because how weird
would it be and uh this is i'm
paraphrasing this joke i'm not releasing
a joke but he goes uh he alludes to how
weird would it be if like if you called
your buddy it was just random monday
like what are you doing let me get on
about five minutes i'm gonna go down to
l.a zoo like what as a grown man better
have kids as a girl you better have kids
you have kids though zoos are different
when zoos were
much better when we were when especially
when you were kid when you're a kid
they're just walking tigers and [ __ ] now
the zoo it's like
did you know this do you know this you
know
china owns they rent every panda you see
in america
china rents the pandas to us to us i
believe that the amount of money they
make off renting pandas is nuts i
believe that we're out on that biden you
know what i'm saying
well do you know how long we let the
chinese influence us they're renting our
pandas
by the way great looking bears perhaps
the most boring bear of all time and i
don't know if you know it might be up
there well but panda bear is literally
they they evolved to eat meat and then
they somewhere along the line stopped
and now they only eat bamboo now the
thing about bamboo don't know if you
know this tough is that you gotta chew
it and eat it 12 hours a day to get
enough nutrition so pandas they sit and
chew on bamboo for 12 hours a day now
they look cute but you're close it's
still bare like someone got mauled in
india from what you know those bears
that have some bears they have like
marks here sun bears you know this is
sun bear
they kill more people than anybody else
well this this couple in india they go
on their morning walks they see a beer
they go there oh that thing's cute let's
go play with them okay and that bear was
like i'm not that that bear looks like
[ __ ] i'm thought the bear with hair that
bear looks like he's missing a few
chromosomes yeah i'm talking about this
the beer with a straight up long hair
the long hair well i think that's the
sun no it's not dude it's not that beer
is stupid
oh there you go that's the suckers yeah
yeah what's it called that's sloth
that's right so this sloth bears in
india they're wild in india yeah couple
in india was like hey you know what
let's go for a walk oh check it out
that's a sloth bear he has long hair
he's probably not dangerous and the bear
went cool story yeah here's what i'm
gonna do for breakfast today what am i
doing i'm kill both you right i'm going
to drag you down by the water and i'm
going to eat you for four hours until
someone stumbles upon me and scurries me
off yeah and that's how the your day's
going to end that's how your day's going
that's what this sloppy beer said i'm
going to do today so there's a video i
don't want to watch of a guy getting
eaten having his ass eaten first by a
sloth
yeah and and sloth bears and sun bears
because of their proximity to farmers
and people in that area
they will uh i think they kill more
people than any other bears and that
that sloth bear that you saw so tigers
will will kill a sloth bear and eat a
sloth bear sure but you can also find
plenty of video on sloth bears going you
know what not today [ __ ]
giving it right back to el tigre now do
they think about that no but they but
the mis but el tiger sher khan runs away
from balu balu sometimes goes [ __ ] you
with a gun
well that's that's what balu is that's a
that's a sloth bear i think or a sun
bear that's an indian bear i think
they're indigenous to india right find
out
but either way uh they uh
they will [ __ ] you up and they will tell
a tiger to go [ __ ] themselves so you
ain't doing nothing against a sloth bear
though those people that died [ __ ]
with the sloth bear it's like they went
up to him because he looks kind of
friendly his haircut that's so dumb
yeah dude and then termites let's talk
about current events with animals do you
hear the the lady that got stomped out
by the elephant
and i think in india clearly india is
just a you know trouble a lot of cobras
a lot a lot of elephants and when one
person gets the flu seven billion that's
right they're on top of that that's
right yeah don't don't tame an elephant
because what happens is what they want
this this [ __ ] i think this is a wild
elephant and you decide to stomp this
[ __ ] out right and then she died and
then the bear came back during her
funeral and stomped out the corpus
oh just i'm not done daddy's not done
stomp stomp stomp stomp oh my
death then attacks her corpse at a
funeral this is a special kind of
elephant peter oh my lord
it's smelled it or something dude his
job wasn't done
oh that's nuts dude come on dude then
then attacked by the same beast at her
funeral are you joking me no man these
elephants yeah no games vindictive
yeah he never forgets elephants never
forget they don't forget elephants well
that's the show in africa in africa my
sister was telling me that they
that the guy had a farm and he had a
donkey that was chained up that had he
had a donkey tied to the some post and
the elephants came to [ __ ] with his
crops and so what he did was he shot a
gun in the air and clapped and scared
them off and like you know did whatever
you had to do just to screw him along
yeah but you know it had to do it like
had to shoot like close to them and
scared the babies and the baby like that
and any i think they scared the babies
off so then the adults went after the
babies
well
well [ __ ] with their kids they came
back in the the next day or you know a
couple days later
um at night that those elephants came
back and stomped that donkey to a
[ __ ] yeah
it was donkey pancakes that they made
donkey pancakes
and uh and that was it it was just and
the guy said well that was for spite
they rolled the donkey out like play-doh
he got mad at us that one of them they
got mad and they came back and [ __ ]
our donkey up just this little something
so no no don't drink the donkey yeah oh
no don't stomp out my donkey we remember
these things god elephants are [ __ ]
yeah and they'll remember
because you know i don't know if you've
ever watched it's it's a tough thing to
watch the way they tame an elephant is
they break an elephant the way they
break an elephant is basically tying it
up and breaking its spirit and things
going uh yeah it's a baby do you know
that no and so they don't forget that
they're gonna watch that you know i
didn't like that now i'm gonna [ __ ] you
up yeah yeah i don't know if they still
do that but that's what they used to do
i've written none of that [ __ ] these
elephants i've never ridden elephants
let's take a little break uh b we're
talking about dinosaurs talking about
amber heard you name it man but listen
are you guys ready for the nba champs to
be crowned join the finals action all
right
that's right you have the freaking
warriors and the boston celtics you can
watch the game and make bank with
draftkings sportsbook the official
sports betting partner the nba new
customers can bet any five dollar nba
bet and get 150 dollars in free bets
instantly look to turn another small bet
into big payday during the nba finals
with draftkings same game parlay you can
do just that this nba season a customer
placed a five dollar same game partly
and won over 5 000 bucks create your own
parlay by combining multiple bets like
which team will win total threes made
total rebounds all that stuff and so
much more boom you have a shot even
bigger payout download draftking
sportsbook app now use promo code
fighter make a any five dollar bet
during the nba finals and get 150
dollars and free bets instantly that's
promo code fighter only at draftking
sportsbook an official sportsman part of
the nba minimum age eligibility
restrictions by see show notes for
details draftking sportsbook promo code
fighter
uh let me talk to you about our newest
sponsor toehold please do you guys like
bespoke flip-flops the highest quality
flip-flops made of herman oak leather
made of crocodile made of sustainable
elephant that all the money goes back to
the game reserves to save elephants if
you want stingray if you want
dragon koi patterns you want a custard
leather dude we use dragon leather okay
i'm not going to spread anything but we
found some dragon leather colossal
raptor yeah we got velocity we use the
skin the membrane either way whatever
you want we've heard that
we have the best we have the best exotic
um leather guy in the world we got the
best leather in the world hermano
leather vegetable tan leather so it's
all natural the way leather was made for
millennia and you will wear these and
they will continue to look good the more
you wear them and they will most likely
be the only flip-flops you ever wear i
it's all it's what i live in it's what i
live in so go to
shoptohold.com
and there's a promo code t-fat k for 15
off they are beautiful you're welcome we
got the patriot by the way we got we got
the where where it's we the people we
got the first amendment second amendment
on there it's pretty badass
i've been on i've been on oh there's a
new dock on uh netflix
it's on the uh the church of latter-day
saints but this the special division
it's like the special forces of
latter-day saints yeah and it's about
that guy forget his name but he took him
young no no no no no no this isn't in
the 1400s dude it's current
it's current so they believe in polygamy
and like multiple wives which is frowned
upon splinter group so yeah so the
they're the special forces of the
mormons so what they did is they're like
cool you're gonna not do this well we're
gonna do our own thing and so it's
called uh keep sweet pray and obey so
it's
warren jeff is the main leader dude so
what he did is they thought he was
special because when he was a baby they
didn't think he would make it his mom
says i talked to god they say he's
special so he got special treatment made
him a sociopath
so then his dad is about to pass away
then he made it so the family members
couldn't see the dad and he goes in
their religion they they thought that
the dad when he passed away he would die
and they'd pop back younger so the dad
dies and they're waiting for him to pop
back
strange enough didn't pop back because
it doesn't work like that right so the
follower's like hey what the hell i
thought he was going to pop back
then this dude jeff warren goes oh he's
he's actually embodied in me he took
over my body i'm the new leader and i'm
terrible so you're gonna do everything i
say and they have 78 wives they go very
cool so what he did and it was super
illegal is he made all these moves so
the women used to dress however they
wanted not anymore he married like his
own mom sisters and then it came out he
was raping like 12 year olds 14. what a
surprise a cult leader raping raping
underage girls never heard of that
before that's why they start a cult dude
this documentary is so fascinating man
and what's interesting too is the way
because i'm like [ __ ] just leave but
what they do
is if you leave you're leaving your
brothers and sisters behind now when
your kid i bet it's licked you have like
80 brothers and sisters and you're
playing non-stop with plato or whatever
yeah but what they made it so
the books that like talked about the
outside world in a positive way they're
cut out of the textbooks so you only
view the outside world it's terrifying
you weren't educated on anything so like
when these girls who married this the
guy who passed away when he was 88 and
they were 19
their first kiss was this old dude and
they didn't even realize how to have a
baby they were they didn't even educate
him on sex so the first night before you
go to bed all the wives would have to
line up and kiss him good night and she
goes the line was so long i [ __ ] hate
i'd wait hours just kiss him say good
night and then he would choose out of
the whatever 80 wise bike all right
you're staying with me tonight
and she was like 18 or 16. i was like
what
and then she goes gets on the bench
spread your legs and she's like i don't
even know i i don't know that saying
many babies then i got pregnant like
it's nuts dude nuts yeah it's it's it's
so they just make sure they're
uneducated and they don't want a guy
who's a cult leader in any country
anywhere i promise is a piece of [ __ ]
they are the cold leader or politicians
same person the cult leaders are there
to [ __ ] they they start a cult so
they can have sex with underage girls or
women in general who are vulnerable dude
the best part is so he makes all these
promises like uh
that jeff warren goes when the olympics
come to salt lake city the town the the
city's going to burn down when you get
out of here so he convinced everyone to
leave and he goes what's going to happen
is
you all of utah in the world is going to
set on fire and those that are the peers
who listen to what i say
the ground is going to break off and
lift above the fire
so what happened was that didn't happen
surprisingly it did the world didn't
catch on fire and then the ground didn't
break off and help them so then they go
hey man well i'm at the ground breaking
off you know what change of plans and so
he just kept like this whole thing wrong
sociopathic and then his next con was if
you got to be the most pure to get to
zion he kept saying this thing zion yeah
well his problem with zion was he wanted
to get there so he moved the family to
somewhere in texas
well that town in texas don't have much
going on but they have people like you
know they love their their town so they
would they're like who is this new group
zion would be the promised land yes the
heinz the promised land but that new
place where they moved in texas that
town so you don't want to [ __ ] with
texans because those texans those people
that live there go we don't have much
going on we love our town this new place
comes in they go oh don't worry about
them i forget what they said they're
doing but they didn't say they were
called this cold yeah but they set up
cameras and stuff and they watch them
the entire time they go huh set up a big
operation here and they go they're also
working through the night like 24 hours
well the advantage and shout out to the
business mind the mormon the special
force mormons here the advantage is
they'd have so many boys so many boys
they would have them do free labor
because that was god's work so they
would work for free slavery god's
slavery yes god's slaves yes sure they'd
have them work for free through the
night to build all their structures
tax free
they work tax free here's what's really
crazy these big corporations would work
with them because they go it's all
profit we don't have to pay for
the labor well the the cost is insane so
walmart started working with them all
these big corporations would work with
them shame on them and did uh what
happened to warren jeff i'm glad you
asked so what happened to him is he get
pulled apart by uh horses uh he he got
trampled to a pancake yeah it's called
drawn and drawn a quarter do you just
tie yeah tie it one school yeah
yeah just have them drive off here no
that'd be cool but what they did is uh
some guy was like this can't be right
man and then
um they started looking more into it and
like how's that girl and they're like 16
and she's pregnant that ain't right
who's who impregnated and they find out
it's an older man so he started looking
more and more into it the fed's got a
hold of it he goes on the run he goes on
the run this dude was half them set i
don't know what he spent his money on he
was having that the family sent him 300
grand in cash a week sometimes more
and then he gets pulled over because
he's driving through vegas he's on the
run at this point because they found out
he's raping these young girls so he's on
the run a cop sees a uh escalate
cadillac escalade with expired plates
pulls it over because you know the
plates are expired
looks in the car go wait is that that's
him they put him in prison so he's on
trial and then uh his new place in texas
they you know obviously raided and then
there was a big like door but it was a
safe so it took him hours the detective
goes you're just here and drilling for
hours and hours and hours finally we
entered in there it's just all the
documents how many people he married
underage who he had sex with and then
they go this is the worst part of the
doc spoiler in three two one then we
found videotapes and uh audio of him
with the
wives around he would have wives around
while he raped a 12 and 14 year old
there's videotape of that so he got 110
years in prison yeah but let's put him
in jen pop so he gets killed that's what
i'm saying daddy but then also my girl
was like i'm surprised they just don't
he didn't get the death penalty i'm like
[ __ ] the death penalty that's too easy
no we want him to suffer in that prison
yeah the only problem is even though he
got busted for all that stuff he still
has thousands of followers who still
[ __ ] with of course so he's still
preaching through a phone and some [ __ ]
writes it down are you serious yeah is
that crazy take that privilege away what
are we doing
uh take that away tell him dude and then
anyone who spoke out against him like
his brother was like a really smart guy
or whatever or there's this guy who
started a business and they go
you're getting too smart for your own
good you the church owns the business so
some guy lost his in complete livelihood
and then they go ah he so he found out
people were like starting to be like man
this thing this isn't going down the
right road we should probably do
something so he has a list people are
snitching on those people he had a list
and they're at conjugation look at him
he reads out all their names and goes
stand up so they say like 12 guys stand
up there's a thousand people there 12 or
14 guys stand up he goes you're you guys
are out you guys are the devil if your
family's around you they're gonna be
relocated with a different dad in our
church and you guys don't don't say
goodbye don't you pack your stuff
there's a van waiting for you outside
there and drive you off the property so
some dads on there like i had 14 kids
who i absolutely loved i've never talked
to him again i had to leave that day
i mean it's you watch as you're like
holy what a terrible human well he needs
to die it's like that's a guy who needs
to just get [ __ ] his head covered now
you guys don't need to watch the doc so
that's cool well that's uh no it's fat i
do it's fat
it's fascinating my thing was like how
stupid can somebody be because then you
realize they're easy to brainwash when
they're kids well when they're kids but
then also
their parents were in it right so that's
all they know and then nobody's educated
so they have no clue no they think the
outside world is your reality
that's your reality baby
wow that's [ __ ] crazy would you
recommend watching it oh it's so good
yeah four-part series so interesting you
did just ruin it for everybody this
story's been out since 2002. yeah i said
i knew this story yeah it's been uh it's
like me ruining my comments like me
ruining wake gopher still in a new
documentary though it came out yeah but
it's an old story yeah me ruining oj for
you not really because this is a new
when this documentary come out you just
ruined the documentary for everybody
this is history you want me to ruin the
jfk assassination i know but it's still
although
yeah i'm still interested i'm gonna
watch oh yeah i'm sorry it's so good
i'll watch it it's so good it's always
there's so much that goes but it's
always the same profile it's always the
same kind of guy always the same kind of
guy
just to [ __ ] he's a real good talker
just you know
yeah
just a [ __ ]
dude it's insane and their whole their
whole
kind of motto is keep it sweet
keep it sweet keep it sweet like even if
you don't feel like doing something keep
it sweet yeah
well scientology is a
bit like that scientology yeah
communication i had my experience with
scientology because i had done some
charity work there i was on a show with
a couple scientologists yeah sometimes
experience it's weird scientology is
still going like you look around yes is
it oh yeah it's booming daddy is it like
you look around la
they own some of the biggest buildings
like their money's oh yeah they have a
lot of money but i think the internet
kind of
put a dent in their membership maybe but
look how much money they have to think
of the buildings
you go to san francisco yeah no they own
a lot of property and then think about
their team captains tom cruise dude
biggest movie in the [ __ ] world
yeah man i still haven't seen top gun
you've seen it oh yeah it's fantastic
fantastic yeah but even
leah remny uh
you know she just throws shade on tom
cruise she's like remember everybody
still scientologists think all right let
him [ __ ] listen that's awesome he
gives a [ __ ] yeah he's still awesome
yeah all right just because he's just
doesn't mean you're an [ __ ] yeah he
might be you know no my question you're
entitled to a scientologist he was my
question intelligence but i knew a
science i was an acting teacher and
somebody said are you a scientologist
and he said i don't know what that means
i've been have i taken a lot of courses
there and got nothing from them yes have
i taken a lot of courses there and
gotten something from them yes if that
makes me a scientologist then that's
fine so you know because at the lower
levels it is just like essentially
self-improvement techniques yeah and
then you get a lot of it's like take
responsibility for yourself
yeah i will say that my experience with
scientologists like across the board has
been that they're super nice
like yeah that's because they're trying
to get you in the church the idea is be
ethical
money honest to communicate directly and
be honest so there's a lot but i don't
you know then then of course like
there's something shady like anything
else right but there's also like they
make you hold those things you see and
you go do a questionnaire they're
recording all of it so if you say
anything then they can hold it again
it's not science though you're like they
they record you it's so weird yeah i
mean tom cruise like when you say like
hey i go
you have to imagine that he's on video
[ __ ] dudes or something and yeah
there's no chance yeah there's a good
thing there
wrote a really good book called going
clear yeah oh that documentary is yeah
yeah it's like a doctor watch the
document and it's one of my favorite
books of all time well my acting class
is featured in that
great deal yeah all right they do talk
about that class for 10 years
we decided to back out so like no big
career for you sir well i did fat
actress with kirstie alley who's excited
every actor we ever had on that show was
a scientologist and we also shot
episodes in the scientology center i
also did a charity for 9 11 in the
scientology in the church science you're
a scientologist yeah that's cool and
raise money for uh scientology so i've
had some experiences and i've known a
lot of scientologists and i have to say
i'll take heat for this but every
scientologist i've met was always really
nice
but i don't i don't think they're known
for being mean like the head dies
unless directed to be with the
harassment well david
if you go after them they'll ruin you
david miscavige is the head he's been
their head since 25 years old nobody
really knows he never he's never in the
limelight they don't even have pictures
and he stays out of it yeah man he's but
he's wrong
i don't know well according to the book
they paint him like as a ruthless
violent
oh if you look it up yeah yeah and will
they say will smith is in scientology
too because one of the things in
scientology their biggest disrespect is
slapping
really so they were saying when will
smith slap chris rock they're like
that's a scientology thing most dudes
would punch him is he a scientist i
don't think will smith is pretty sure
i would guess that he is based on
whatever but again you i don't know the
degree to which like you do something
and maybe they have something on you or
there's some deal or whatever because
it's like you'd want to have those
people in and yeah be able to say it and
so they're not getting the harassment or
abuse but right right these people who
are out of the ship or whatever
or in this compound on the desert it's
not a scientologist
yeah
fixer and senior executive mike rinder i
was in 2017 i guess realistically that
guy
but that's the rumors he's trying to
that's why the slapping is in
scientology they slap he's like he's
gone quiet for a little bit here huh he
has to lay low
lay low let the storm just fall all over
you and then pop back up yep
and uh because netflix pulled some of
his movies too
they did oh yeah damn yeah bright two
and another movie supposed to do and
they're like we're gonna fall off for
now whoa makes sense
you never know just who killed that
temperature i don't give a [ __ ] yeah i
mean whatever dude
uh yeah
uh jada pinkett smith school was um
where they had their own school
yeah whatever but she tried to get
chris and him back together and
essentially a scientology school she
wanted
she was calling for them to reconcile
maybe on the red table it's like all
right
i'm sure you are
i'll tell you what's interesting i
understand how it works but i'm addicted
to
the nasal spray the afrin
because once you start using more than
three days it says it says on the bottle
don't use it it's really bad for your
liver i don't want you doing that
for your nose yeah well for your but i
don't get why why is it addictive i mean
it's a dancer you can't breathe without
it but i looked online last night i'm
saying you just got to go cold turkey
doesn't able to see if that says that
do you get cravings for like how is it
addictive no i just like to breathe no
okay so there's nothing wrong with my
nose clogged
inhaled yeah i don't want you taking
that stuff bubba
all right i'll stop because what happens
bob is that your your nose will will uh
uh your nose will actually clog up
without it so it starts getting
conditioned i know who are you telling
yeah that's what i'm saying that's why
you're addicted to use it all the time
that's why people get addicted because
you want that yeah there's nothing about
liver damage than that yeah there is
that no i don't think so that's
something else
no it wasn't on there yeah it says uh
you have to get rid of your liver after
look
let me see let me see we're gonna
[Music]
you gotta get a new liver right there
this isn't right
yeah it'd be weird that's bad for your
liver but um yeah for your nose yeah it
re it constricts the blood using it
because i was sick and then my nose was
clogged and so you just want to unclog
it and then you have to use it if you
want nose unclogged yeah but then i was
reading you can go colder it takes a few
days to get off of it then your body
starts working itself out or you can use
the saline solution that is not as good
i like saline i'm gonna do it after
after the show today i'm gonna get off
it because i don't have to keep your
septum might be torn you got stuff
behind it so use saline to flush it out
you know
significantly more potent than other
kinds of decongestants yeah
constrictor yeah and that's why your
nose clogs up
it's nice though i [ __ ] hate having a
cold god damn it
it's just when you want to get that [ __ ]
out of your nose and then you know yeah
then you're stuck on it not a good hair
guy after the old teeth maybe daddy
tackles the old hair who knows oh the
like the plugs i mean yeah but we'll see
like a barber no there's no there's no
cloning yet uh-huh
maybe i'll go maybe go take a look let's
take a look
huh there's some celebs out there with
terrible hair you know he used to have
awful hairs and machine gun kelly and
then he got a haircut
look at his locks now may i see some
before and after dude before dude do you
look too awful is that true yeah
young you've never done regularly
regular micro needling right
because that can be extremely effective
no like at a certain way and there's
like machines that do it too i'm just
losing my hair oh look at that yeah i'm
telling people who have no who have less
hair than you regrow it just with
microneedling and minoxidil just find
out what machine gun kelly did that kid
was losing his house
complete transformation look at that
that could be you man
boy look at that good looking kid you
know they do a lot of hair transplants
huh the hot spot for hair transplants in
the world is turkey is nimble oh yeah
yeah but i'm going to i'm going a facial
plastic surgeon who knows his [ __ ]
a facial plastic so when you're so
there a lot of guys who do hair
transplants are dermatologists or er
surgeons who've taken a lot of classes
plastic surgeons their hands it's it's a
different touch it's a different thing
all together you gotta i would just be
like all right what celebrity have you
worked on dude there you go you know i
mean whoever did his hair i'll take that
hair i know not gonna happen look at
that it's not gonna happen
because i gotta
you have the back of your head has i
would assume a line yeah no does that
have scoring yeah because i had noticed
i did it so does it back in 1920
they they take out a whole me and rogan
they take out a [ __ ] like
you have a healthy donor
maybe because like for example women
with autoimmune disorders
they'll have like
patchy hair throat like jada pinkett
smith you can't do a hair transplant
when the whole head has unhealthy hair
but if it's androgenic alopecia you can
take these hairs back here are thick
yeah that's what you put up from that's
what he tried i did it now with the
strip they're getting so much better at
it really yeah it was a hot sauce
increase maybe
now let's see if it's realistic i wonder
how much it is yeah you need to go
someone who can guarantee the results i
got the guy then you have the eye now
let me ask you this same guy that did
your lids let's pass on that though
right right because that didn't work did
it i did i'm good-looking i did it very
minimal sure i did all i did so i look a
little less tired sure you
didn't do anything dude i look adorable
remember when you came in the studio the
next day it was hilarious oh my god
just [ __ ] just waste time though yeah
so let's not go to him so let's uh we
gotta go to hair guy bag what celebrity
did you work on well he's worked on all
the celebs
we'll see dude i don't know i don't buy
that yeah we need proof oh i got proof
i got proof it can't be cheap
that's the problem how should they tell
you also do i care also should i just oh
you want me answer that for you yeah
yeah that's all you talk about yeah yeah
you care yeah but is it gonna make a
diff you did your eyes yes but is it
gonna my eyes are different
cause i thought i'd be on camera and i
was starting to get droopy eyes and it
was gonna get worse and worse because my
my family has to get it that was more
like i you know you get this in my
family crazy on my mother's side i think
the hair mothers want to try
i think the hair would be life-changing
for you and a big difference in outcomes
by the way is how you treat it
afterwards because really it's about
getting blood flow to those new graphs
so if you treat it well and do what they
say and like continue to do protocols
it's like kind of annoying it's like new
grass like new grass you're out of water
daddy so some people do it and they it
all falls out again because they didn't
do the steps afterwards to make it i
feel like now it's such a science that
so many dudes are doing oh so many you i
look at results all the time online well
there are topicals and stuff and all
that we'll see correct maybe
it could be fun like maybe after that in
addition to debt depends how much it
cost though right it's probably 70 costs
a lot it's probably 20 grand that'd be
worth it i actually looked into it for a
little bit did you you did yeah why so
because i wanted to see because i was
like i'm still like
yeah thinning hair so then
i looked at prp which they do for hair
they do stem cells right now that
doesn't work for her no so i want the
new age [ __ ] i need i need so they work
but they cost
for pr sorry uh for a stem cell it'll
last about a year maybe
the most they've tried it fifty four
hundred dollars no i saw the results and
stuff yeah well that's their best case
scenario and you need the real [ __ ] but
as far as transplanting yeah uh i i
wouldn't even qualify for it my donor
hair is not good enough for
transplanting [ __ ] so you have to have
good donor hair to even get the
transplant they won't do that couldn't
like mark donate hair to you to the top
give me 1100 grass you piece of [ __ ] uh
if they cut my the back of my scalp
i'm surprised they can't do that no they
would take it follicle by follicles so
you'd have to just sit in there i'll
take forever no i can't do that you
can't watch a couple of movies no no
i'll buy you a great bottle of wine
i don't want to do that come on man i
can't believe they can't do that i
wonder if they can like if maybe if they
could take donor hair from you your body
rejects it okay they cloned hair but
they couldn't get color into it
[ __ ]
oh that'd be cool if you're like
anderson cooper if i look like a polar
bear
it was just all silver yeah that looked
dope it's just they can't i think it's
like see-through though they couldn't
get color into it
not weird yeah but what's alarming me is
guys like lebron and donald trump who
have all the money they've tried it and
it's just not but if they don't have the
donor hair it doesn't it's not gonna
work it's not gonna take sometimes
you're just bald your hair's pretty thin
in the back too b it's getting thinner
and thinner it's not thick in the back
it doesn't help that i also keep it so
short i'm going to grow it a little bit
longer no you're not no
[Music]
come on yeah yeah you don't know
why because i'm just too lazy to do it
yeah you would have done it by now you
know yeah
i tackled the teeth when are you getting
your invisalign
i was supposed to go in
they called you and said to me you found
anything else to do
i get it not for i no i had an
appointment i had appointment with them
and i had a meeting and i went to her
schedule the website's tough so you know
i don't know i have some time off now i
can probably go in yeah
i would like to do it yeah but just the
toothpaste they gave me made my teeth
feel better really oh yeah way better
the old fluoride i was using like a
hippie toothpaste without fluoride and
he was like dude charcoal throw that in
the garden yeah he's like you need
fluoride you need fluoride you need
[ __ ] core so now daddy's still you
know i had half of voodoo donut before
my teeth almost fell out that's cool
good though huh
yeah the best mark had 17 of them
they're so easy mark you ate some voodoo
doughnuts do you have a cheat day
uh on the road he goes yeah i don't like
really and i yes
i'm not an like optimal body fat right
now but
i just never let it go that like when
i'm back home i just don't eat unhealthy
because yeah you're on a house of like
so if you have two days or three days on
the road of eating like [ __ ] yeah and
you can here's how you know
fast for a day that can often make
especially when you talk about like
because i get the same thing with water
retention you eat sugar and carbs it's
really more like oh you feel kind of
unwilling
mark and i had facials on saturday what
it was so relaxing what'd they do they
did they take blackheads out or i mean
they can but this was more about just a
cleaning well no she's she started to do
the blackheads i was like hey haley are
you on stage tonight so i can't have my
face all red yeah she's like oh we just
do massage then
chinese lady was great that's a good
chinese accent too yeah she was great
yeah i was so relaxed i fell asleep
barted for sure
i'm sure i did that's what woke me up
oh my bad
that's bad did she massage any part of
your body like your shoulders and stuff
she did my shoulders my hands my wrists
which i love my wrist massage
oh i've had a massage in a [ __ ]
time dude and uh dave was like man
you're all gay i was like dude the
facials make me gay yeah then i'm
ready so nice reminding me to go like
once a month yeah because like my skin
was a lot better after this all this
[ __ ] i didn't have
thailand i had a pedicure where they do
your feet i didn't like it well i hate
that i don't like it i grasped me over
there one time
right because i had an ingrown toenail
and i could hear him talking [ __ ] about
me even though it was in my language
whatever dude yeah i don't like that no
i don't like that either now you can
give me a facial you can give me a
massage but also on the on the pedicure
they they they try to get off the rough
on your feet i need that like yeah
working out and like i need those like
when they get rid of that your feet hurt
so bad right i don't like that i don't
need soft [ __ ] feet no facials i'll
take all day
it's nice
besides your shoulder your neck they get
your temples then also like my sinuses
so they massage all that out yeah i got
in a mud bath once oh yeah how was that
it was pretty wild in america or
somewhere else apparently the mud pulls
all the yeah it's good for toxins yeah
which you know what you know elephants
have been using it for for decades you
ever see when they asked all these these
people these people like mud masks they
asked all these practitioners they went
who are detox like specialists with all
that stuff and they went to them one
afternoon they're like what what toxins
are you taking out of this doctor
because what toxins are you taking out
of the body because he specialized in
detox for alcoholics where your liver
detoxes
but like when you say i'm going to detox
i'm going to sweat out toxins
uh this that's not science it's not a
measurable science dr drew i said that
to adam what what toxins what toxic yeah
i think it's [ __ ] it goes with toxins
your body's always detoxing with your
kidneys in your liver so when you say
when you say i'm going to sweat out
those toxins and you're not throwing
them out now they will they they kept
going they go where are the talks do you
know what toxins you're talking about
all more like well the heavy metals
really just talk let's take a look at
the sweat and see if there are any heavy
metals
but it's good to sweat like it's good it
is good to get like any sort of liquid
moving
so exercise gets lymphatic fluid moving
to your body and and so they've done
some interesting studies about athletes
athletes actually typically are
have like uh i think one in four people
die of cancer if they live to a certain
age you know
and in athletes who are pro athletes one
in seven or one in ten wow so they think
it's just the
amount
yeah the constant movement movement is
very good for you obviously movement
like so so every time they talk about
all these supplements and stuff yeah but
sleep
less food
sunshine
and
exercise yeah like far and away yeah far
and faster
everything else is like um
like if you look at the people that live
the longest like if you look at the blue
zones the latter the the the seventh-day
adventists up in san luis obispo uh
sardinia they're talking about they're
tiny but yeah no the the people at the
seven-day adventists are not but um but
if you and there's certain places in
china where they they eat a lot of
yogurt
almost all the meat
some form of meat yogurt some kind of
fermented food but they also like garden
they move around a lot and they have
strong communities
almost all of them every every one of
them strong communities huge yeah i say
to that doctor yeah no [ __ ] dude you
know
what [ __ ] but but people think it's like
well if i do this fish oil then i take
this no no no no but not if you're not
the red but if the rest of your life is
a [ __ ] hole of course that's not good
well that's like the rats right when
they they were saying rats will keep
doing cocaine until they die hell yeah
until
you give rats all the cocaine they want
but then over here they can go to rat
disneyland where they have all their
friends where they can play have sex
they can do they're going over there
they stop doing i'm sure there's still a
few rats doing that cocaine almost none
that was there's one badass yeah so when
they were doing those rat things with
coconuts
really sterile cage yeah that's all they
were doing once they gave them a whole
community of other rats they stopped
doing it yeah no
besides that like oh it's so addictive
that it's the chemical hooks model of
addiction versus you know yeah having
community and purpose and self-esteem
all those other things that you should
you know so so you know when you don't
want to go off to against a parole board
you know the last time when what part
what time of the day do you think is you
do not want to go up for after lunch
before lunch before because everyone
let's get out i'm hungry they're hungry
they're like let's just do this man i
don't want to come on guilty
yeah this is really studying it was like
astonishing how many damn people are
there their tummies make a difference i
already got jen
all right real quick um with brushing
your teeth did you guys know that i
heard this on a podcast so you're not
supposed to rinse your mouth after you
brush your teeth you're supposed to
brush your teeth and spit out the rest
of the toothpaste
they wipe your face on your face
well they get hurt they give me a work
properly they give me a really intense
fluoride where i
leave it on at night and then just spit
out the extra and then leave it on yeah
but don't rinse it out with water now
yeah it stays on the teeth yeah that was
a surprise to me i was like what the
hell i don't like the way that feels in
my mouth neither do i i'm so useless my
girl does that i just don't get it i'm
like it's supposed to be the way to go
to prevent cavities yeah i should have
known that
38 years ago yeah
i could have used a while ago though
brushing your tongue scraping and
brushing your tongue is important from
the roof of your mouth
um let's start with this one
wait that's not the one
hold up hold up
how about this one i said oh yes
i thought this was fake jay showed me
that can't be real he's probably just
[ __ ] around you watch the video like
oh half his face is paralyzed
because they said he canceled his shows
in toronto like but it's not covered to
relate him like he's probably you know
he struggles with mental health and all
that [ __ ] like you may just depress
something if you don't want to dance and
sing in your hometown yeah but yeah no
he's like nah [ __ ] half my face is
paralyzed
and how did it happen
uh so so they think that uh when you're
like exhausting stuff you can catch
these viruses so bell's palsy same kind
of thing bell's palsy can sometimes be
perfect it's a virus yeah bell's
policies that way you lose the you the
nerves just die in your face and they'll
come back but sometimes they don't
my buddy my buddy half his face like
that well there's a rapper el chapo or
something like that he i guess he had it
and trying to contact bieber and there's
a hashtag uh dr chopa was going around
because he's like hey i know the exact
way to get rid of this he's like hit me
up i know exactly how to deal with this
because i guess he had it oh wow
a painful rash around the ear on the
face around the mouth yeah
so it's probably it's not like something
that's oh that's what he has is ramsay
hunt syndrome that's what it says
and uh
how do you get rid of it
i think you have to wait it out you just
gotta chill yeah see if it's the same as
bell's palsy see what i see how it says
that
let me do this real quick how long does
it take to go away a few weeks
should get better in a few weeks if
there's not much nerve damage you should
get better completely within a few weeks
so the damage is more superior you may
fully not fully recover wow but what but
it doesn't say what cause what
it's like
instead of virus the virus does fall
patients with ramsay huntsman often have
more severe paralysis at onset oh that's
like i mean he's still dancing dude and
they're less likely to recover
completely interesting whoa he might
have a little bit of a lazy eye but you
still dance and sing it's [ __ ] up
though man let me protect that voice
daddy yeah that's [ __ ] up caused by
the
varicella zoster virus yeah and and
shingles
damn affects the facial nerves
yeah i mean
that's stress and lack of sleep and all
that [ __ ] traveling
maybe i don't think he just got inspired
i don't think people realize what
someone like that like what the physical
exertion and the travel being on tour oh
my god like
uh
what's her name
uh the girl taylor swift yes
she had been touring for 365 days and
almost every other day or day she would
go to a different city she'd be on a
plane you go crazy that's a year-long
tour you make all the money but
oh it's a [ __ ] though think about that
you've made 600 million dollars no but
you're shot chanting and moving around
you know when i signed up for it you
know you make a lot of money but it's
made all of you don't take care of
yourself it'll [ __ ] you up though you
think you'd have someone like there with
your trainer with you a dietitian yeah
because singing is happening there's 600
million right
she's dancing and singing that's a
physical she's not dancing she doesn't
no no she don't dance anymore she's on
stage guitar flat ass
chin loves her so it's jay they like the
i like crowbar mine is my girl i think
she's amazing
yeah be careful though self-care
everybody everybody what's this here we
go how about the guy who came her
ex-husband who came to the wedding with
a knife he got beat down huh got the
[ __ ] beat out of him what a dick he's in
her house
it's like really dude what yeah her axe
came to raid kevin federline no no you
don't have time for that the first guy
she married not k fed how are you like
first guys like our high school the
first guy came back tried interrupting
the wedding got beat down
yeah so this is uh the their
she's getting married again to her
boyfriend and has an iron-clad prenup in
place
he joked earlier that he was the one who
wanted the prenup because uh he wanted
to protect his shoe collection
yeah he was like was she gonna get my
[ __ ] 92 civic like he's a trainer or
something right i think that's how he
met her he's like a personal trainer or
some [ __ ] makes yeah i know he's in the
fitness world yeah uh
what do you guys think about that
about prenups yeah britney spears i have
one all day like this guy this trainer
you've been dancing your ass off yeah
you're not getting half my [ __ ] dude
you don't know his motives either
right there's this [ __ ] joker right
there
oh that the guy the the chubby guy yeah
that's her ex yeah he's he's tried to be
an mma fighter it didn't work out he's
exercising jason alexander across the
event hours before it started was
arrested
oh interesting that it was before it
started
we tried before they said their vows man
he said not today yeah
wow
yeah i mean prenups make sense
if you're britney spears like these
percent automatically a 24-hour fitness
training what if you're a wealthy guy
going into a relationship you're both
wealthy no wealthy guy going into let's
say johnny depends it depends if you
have well johnny abandoned her 100
percent have a prenup all she does is
aquaman too but um
if you have kids different animals
because you have kids you're going to
want to take care of her because then it
affects the kid's life yeah there's kids
involved different animals being see if
johnny depp collects i don't think he
will from her apparently not yeah
are still out there right like literally
[ __ ] uh attacking his character and
it's like hey you guys better shut the
[ __ ] up or i'm gonna you know sue them
yeah yeah i mean you know she's getting
it's also over you lost honey yeah
they're lost but i think for johnny depp
it's worth more than just the money
because his reputation salvaged
incorrect he's bigger than ever correct
and she's eight eight million in the
hole yeah and technically if you if he
wants to he can put a lien on any
earnings she has and for the rest of her
life that's going to be tied up that
she's going to try and appeal that's
going to be yeah
i know all but all of it's you know i
mean but some lawyers are going to take
that on some more take that on and go
just give me the judge grant an appeal
like sometimes it's hard
based on what you know
because a lot of times an appeal has to
be on based on like
a spectacular jury instructor yeah he's
given prenups makes sense to like dr dre
you know who did the beats by dre worth
a billion dollars no what's interesting
is he's with his wife forever right
and then they were going to divorce and
he goes cool let me just give you
whatever 350 million will call it even
she's like nope i want half he's like
cool let's go to court he wins in court
and she's getting nowhere near that
amount yeah but he was trying to be cool
like i'm gonna give you 350 million we
got our separate ways she went [ __ ] you
i want half because he's worth a billion
350 mil
and now she's getting payless run
my buddy went through a terrible divorce
i never forgot this he went through a
terrible divorce and uh
he was literally he was so
it ruined his life for a year my mother
had to get on the phone with him i
remember my mother got on the phone
because she was keeping the kid from
and the judge
like looked at the evidence and the
judge goes hold it like quote he goes
hold it i see what's going on here all
right yep uh i'm gonna i'm gonna render
the judgment here uh you because he was
paying all her lawyer bills and
everything else you have to pay her and
he was like
and he goes
one
dollar really yeah
shaq because you know they were living
in california because kids go to sierra
canyon when they filed for a divorce he
took a private jet bee line before she
could file in california and filed in
florida because they're a little more
lenient there i know california's a
[ __ ] yeah i think do we know
that guy we have a we might have music a
guy i know who was in a divorce oh yeah
he was in a divorce uh about to go
through a divorce with his wife
and what he did was he went and talked
to every big divorceler in the city
every single one of them
and so that they would have a conflict
of interest told him all about the case
that they could that she couldn't hire
any good lawyer yeah it's funny that's
kind of a [ __ ] them that's a gangster
[ __ ] that's exhausting but yeah that's
good he did it
let's get you
oh you guys talking about amber heard uh
so have you guys seen this video yet
no amber heard it's the first time she's
talked on air
to anyone about the whole case
and you guys will not like her i'm sure
hold on there's no polite way to say it
the jury
looked at the evidence you presented
they listened to your testimony and they
did not believe you
their job is to look at the facts and
she doesn't believe her and they did not
believe
yeah your testimony or your evidence
wouldn't you just go while i was telling
the truth
again um how could they after listening
to three and a half weeks of testimony
about how i was a nun credible person
not to believe a word that came out yeah
the same opportunity but you have the
samurai you you had a defense that made
me uncomfortable because i don't believe
her there actually made me she's
terrible lying no no human acts like
that
hey you lied about it how could you even
she can't help it though she there's
nothing she's not good enough actor to
pull it off yeah she can't help it man
you can yeah
with the thing with her face and looking
down you're like you're crying you're
like come on no yeah you she's so
screwed you'd be outraged like i told
her she's super hot though
she looks better than two she's gonna
chill i'm sure she can [ __ ] in my bed
what's that she's [ __ ] myself she's
she's beautiful she her best bet is to
get some very rich dude to pay her oh
that happened again her dm's are just
100 percent she's gonna get on ryan or
you know
uh [ __ ] yeah she'll find a guy she'll
find a rich guy sugar baby doctor she'll
be able she'll be fine yeah she'll be
fine i don't know some billionaires very
hard though to go through the world
where people hate you that much that's a
lot of it's not that's not online hate
that's hate when she walks down the
street 100 people driving down the
street that's real hate that's real
and it comes from women and it comes
from middle schoolers they're all
watching it comes from girls you had a
bit about
yeah i mean uh you know
she's she's going through it well she's
some billionaire but here's the thing if
she she sucks as a human you can tell
yeah so those those looks go away about
after two weeks i'd say maybe even three
days she's around your house just sucks
yeah well i don't she's she's also bad
left and right
i'd be like hey hey you gotta stop that
i have a great listen amber i have a
great time with you but you got to stop
[ __ ] the bed i'm not having fun
anymore it smells awful in here well you
got to please stop shooting my bed yeah
yeah you can't could you use the
bathroom i will i'm not going to run
away you can't mark your territory like
this this is not how to do it if you
want to piss even that's weird but yeah
do your thing that might be [ __ ] yeah
sprinkle a little pee in the corner the
house smells like [ __ ] you can't put
like i have a massive house did you see
did you see postmates i sent it to you
did you see postmates um pride nobody
responded huh no wait for something i
know they i did that on purpose oh you
did yeah i sent it to you
neither one of us responded the
postmates uh did you but did you watch
it bub no but it's about a a diet so
your pooper's clean yeah so so so
a bottle for gay pride week if you're a
bottom in a relationship
post mates is sponsoring they teamed up
with dr evan goldstein is what you
should eat and it's uh it's uh you sent
it away before you said you sent to me
and rogan you're looking at just me
sorry yeah it's it was um
it's it's a bottoms you got it right
there jim pride's uh commercial post
commercial it's
phenomenal there you go right there
bottom front watch this
one company however has gone above and
beyond their call of duty with a bottom
friendly menu backed by science yes you
heard that right please take a look and
listen carefully but if you're a bottom
you're expected to start
not this pride introducing the bottom
friendly menu from postmates
[Music]
we teamed up with dr evan goldstein from
bespoke surgical to bring you a menu of
bottom friendly foods backed by science
every one of these foods they want to
drop something different
huh it's saying to eat that so your
whistle is clean yeah
i mean i don't think this is messy i
don't think it's good to avoid dairy too
if you can't you can't like it's all
that they're telling you what to eat
like postmates is sponsoring us so
they'll send you a butt friendly so you
can be a good bottom so your rump is
great
porn stars eat salad that's what the the
when they're going to do anal they eat
salad the day before that i mean i'd
like that info just got to clean your
whistle i don't want to blow up that
[ __ ] southwest bathroom yeah but that
is like
like whoa that's uh that's interesting
yeah that's interesting that's uh
very interesting okay
don't eat carbs basically like this how
you get your [ __ ] clean so you can
get powdered it's just it's weird right
but i noticed that with keto you're like
what does come out is more dense right
when you're eating carbs it just tends
to be softer
keto comes flying out like goddamn slip
and slide big
slimey eating maybe it's an eating in a
deficit but i just it would come out but
like it would be like in discreet
my my thing about everything left over
yeah my thing about all this when you
have drag queens doing story time for
kids and you have uh these great these
kids were there at the gay pride thing
because i think their school brought
them there and the guy was like suck my
dick he had this thing wow and so what
happens is you know i think that
uh transgender people uh uh drag queens
um
even
anything like that that that is not the
norm that is a minority that is a true
minority and i think when you treat it
like it's the norm right that's the only
thing so for example like with the the
swimsuit issue okay with sports
illustrated with that heavy gallon yes
that that is
sports illustrated and you know you
could make the argument sports
illustrated is using and manipulating
that's all they're doing that woman is
it's a cash graphic yes and so same with
postpartum so not everybody gets to be
playing in the nfl not everybody gets to
be a sport so one of the things about
sports illustrated swimsuit models is
that all of us go that's a very rare
human being i've never seen a girl like
that they have a bone structure and
that's banks right that's like so when
you see tara banks that's the reason we
buy it is it's all of us go that's so
funny the universe and all of us pretty
much cross-culturally like hit the hip
to waist ratio and all that symmetry
that's like everybody in every people
just see beauty even infants will look
at a face that's symmetrical longer than
a face that's not it's just where our
eye goes and the reason is very rare
it's a very rare looking human being so
when you put anybody on the cover you
know whatever it might be and
it's like you're saying that there are
no standards of beauty right which is
and and i would even argue that the
reason that girl's pretty on on sports
illustrated pretty chubby girl yes but
chubby though what your what you're
calling pretty is that she approximates
the symmetry of the women that were on
there well they're trying to move the
goal post yeah that's all they're doing
yeah and i don't buy it i don't believe
it but
you're acting like everybody's on
youtube yeah they're not no the majority
of america is like okay
right uh sports illustrates doing just
to get clicks like well they're doing it
to get to click awoke box or something
and all this stuff but they're also
doing it because we're talking when's
the last time you talk about a sports
illustration you're right covered you're
right so that's all they're doing it for
yeah it's smart smart or is it not
now go to the owner sports illustrated
or the the whole
team and go uh do you date a fat girl
you did no god no but why i thought
there was a marker for beauty well
that's not my type okay cool uh who the
guy who owns sports is right real quick
do you date a chubby girl no that's
something i think well hold on well can
i stop can i do
let me do one more so
the hip to weight waste ratio that even
congenitally blind men like so it's
what's uh 30 70 or something like that
whatever it is
do you know that that actually is
correlated with uh fertility with that's
childbearing hips yeah so you have a
better chance of getting pregnant so
so
health-wise health-wise also if you're
thinner and more athletic
like i told my girlfriend that's
probably no you're meant to have kids
right yes and so why when you're sexist
like you're right but listen right
well it's not is it sexist or is it
nature that's why i told her i was like
you know it's science you can you can
argue against nature nature's always
stronger than nurture like you can you
can keep pushing against nature but at
the end of the day there's a reason
amber hurts going to marry a billionaire
even after all this [ __ ] well maybe you
have to keep [ __ ] in beds but the thing
is is
with uh look but with sports illustrated
i guarantee if they didn't sell more
magazines or get more notoriety like in
a positive like ad sales on this yeah
guarantee you next year there's not a
chubby girl on the cover yeah guarantee
it they go back to it exactly same thing
with netflix something with disney yes
bottom line look at the nfl yeah the nba
when's the last time the nfl nba you
heard him talk about racism remember
that yeah not anymore because americans
went oh we're out there no no we're just
we're just [ __ ] around we're not
that's not going to know that's what
happened right that's what happened and
then you look at netflix the whole woke
movement all that stuff
america went oh we're on subscribing now
where they say hey man if you don't
agree with this you can leave
that's what i thought bill again it's
like you're into diversity except for
diversity of thought until it starts
diversifying your money yeah and then
they're like oh no no no no yeah the
only killer we like here is green but
that's how i feel like i'm i i love the
marketplace it the marketplace says that
that's profitable that that making a
a a man a woman and you know in the ad
and stuff do it if you can do it if
you're making money bro i'm not going to
say [ __ ] if that's what people want i'm
not going to argue but i don't think it
does no i will bet you any amount of
money because even people who are gay
didn't like that diet for your clean
[ __ ] guarantee you next year they
don't do that again yeah
yeah it's all bottom bottom bottom line
bottom dollar
yeah i bet you disney doesn't have
another
gay cast member because this buzz
lightyear movie i bet you it takes a hit
because parents are going we don't want
our son like it's banned in china it's
abandoned oh so so they won't so
it comes out comes out friday there's a
gay character it's a the female gay
character kisses another female well a
lot of parents i don't care i'll take my
sensei on friday i don't go but he he's
not even gonna notice but some parents
like oh we don't support that so then
disney takes a hit to their wallet they
can't sell the international because
international sure as [ __ ] don't play
this game guarantee it's the last time
they do a gay character
because you know it's bottom line i'm so
i don't know i actually don't know what
to say about that like i don't really
know
the gay character i don't have a problem
yeah i don't know what it's tough it's
still i don't i think that parents don't
want
disney
discussion we're going to teach you
about sexuality disney was always a
company but it didn't really have that
they had the prince kissed a gal oh
aladdin jasmine yeah like they do
sexuality but they do it straight the
status quo let me ask you but let's say
and he's not but let's say your son was
gay your daughter was gay right would
you not want them to have something to
look at and be motivated or have someone
that's why that's why it's kind of like
black panther that's why i find myself
kind of on the on the fence i'm like you
know i don't want to say that that's
that is a reality and my kids are going
to come and have already come to the to
the realization that there are
people that are attracted to the same
sex and i would remind people like for
ever when you were attracted to the same
sex you weren't just ostracized a lot of
times you were jailed or killed
i mean [ __ ] oscar wilde was put in
jail for being a homosexual so
you know i don't want to live in a world
like that and i think we've come a long
way so so i think it's an educational
thing but i think disney's
it's tough right right right right
disney's you draw the line somewhere
like how far are you to go with it like
i'm not going to knock are you are you
going to make woody a transgender you
know what i'm saying like is the next
moana transgender and then my son's like
hold on is that a man or like it's
confusing well it's very confusing to
children man 100 you know when you start
saying a man's man when you take
categories away and and you you're
taking you're saying that a biological
man can be in female sports which i'm
totally against because i don't think
it's fair i'm just not saying that but i
think yeah but i think that's the next
step right so
i don't think you're that's been extreme
no no i i i i don't have a problem with
it i would never not take my kids to the
movie it depends
you know what i'm saying it just depends
how far they go with it yeah it depends
how far they go because your son's gonna
be
it's gay confused you know it's it's
but that that's why like the new the
spider verse is dope because it was the
first
you know non-white character that blew
up and the kid who i think was uh his
mom was like puerto rican the dad was
black so people loved that movie and
then if you're a little kid and you're
colored you're like oh that's dope
because soup i don't [ __ ] with superman
don't [ __ ] with toby mcguire yeah i
don't [ __ ] with the flashlight
so now i can relate to this that's why
black panther is cool i get that but how
far are you gonna go with it you know
i'm saying before the other thing is
it's america i know it but it's tough
the other thing is like with the gay
stuff it's like
i truly believe some people are born gay
man or born inside the wrong body
it's a shame it must be awful you know
it's really not to be it used to be
tough to be gay gays now now you're
you're accepted which is great
i don't think so i think because we're
in this bubble in hollywood yeah
go to fort wayne indiana go to boise go
to texas yeah go to a lot of parts of
america where it still ain't cool
we're in hot this weird bubble dude it
ain't cool but now it's easier
than it was they're still getting killed
for it they still can't don't feel safe
to come out yeah like that's [ __ ] up
like because if you're a lot of shames
if you're born that way yeah think how
awful it must be dude awful dude well
you get teased as a kid when you were
gay when i was growing up when i was
growing up and you were you were gay i
remember this very well when you were
gay as a kid
you were not allowed to tell anyone and
it was an acceptable prejudice it was
always the 50s but now
70s 80s
90s it's changed somewhat but we act
like it's all good it's not look at the
suicide right look at the death rate
yeah so you have to do some where these
kids
if they're educated on it you know they
might be like oh that's we're not going
to make fun of them i i don't know so i
don't know so then let me ask you this
so so disney has a gay character which i
don't have like again i'm i am not going
to criticize that how gay though you
know what i'm saying no but but it's a
girl kissing a girl yeah i like how they
went there they didn't do the boy
kissing boy they went girl kissing girl
that's a kind of gay you know i mean
like it's kind of sexy you know what i
mean like let's just dip our toe but
but having said that
like i think that's kind of gutsy and
maybe they will take a hit financially
but they're also they're also i think in
five years or 10 years
we'll it'll find its balance and i don't
think i don't i don't know if it does
finance bounce because still you're
still talking about the minority and the
majority is always going to say yeah we
don't want this [ __ ] yeah and then and
then money speaks so if you're disney
like all right we tried you know yeah
it's a die it's a tough subject man it's
a tough subject
because my initial reaction when they
said oh disney uh is because what they
said originally what came out was the
new buzz lightyear is gay and i was like
oh i'm not seeing that i'm going to take
myself buzz lightyear's you know how
how far are they going to take it yeah
it's just a kiss even that's like my son
who's not gay if he goes oh why is buzz
lightyear kissing another boy oh that's
that's what we do it's like no no no
no i think what i i let me say this like
i don't have any problem with disney
putting a gay character in their movie
what i have a problem with is any
corporation trying to push an ideology
on on me or my children especially yeah
that that's not your job your job is to
be honest i'll take it from here disney
yeah yeah i'll tell you what i mean
let's let's not get into the dark paths
of walt disney yeah i don't want i'll
take it from well let me ask just give
me the gut like no i need you to make
the park less crowded yeah it's not even
it's not in zoos by the way everybody
had a purple tongue from [ __ ] ice i
like those snow cones
those are nice those aren't oh dude it
was a hot day just laboring i'll feed it
to them from the giraffes
giraffe my uh cotton candy yeah that
happened one time he stole my cotton
candy
oh yeah they were there they freaked out
the kids were leaning all the way over
playing almost petting the dragon we can
feed them and i cotton candy ate the
cotton candy and the owners
freaked the [ __ ] out i guess giraffes
with sugar does not go well no
apparently murdered everybody yeah yeah
yeah this is a great candy yeah that was
the great murder of 97. cotton candy
denver zoo shout out denver zoo
hopefully that giraffe's still alive i
was diabetes i went to the denver zoo i
went to the uh
yeah in the middle of the city heart of
the city too right in that trey creek
area
oh yeah me and jay were talking about it
this weekend well you were in a car too
mark we're talking about if you had to
because we're talking about how shitty
cities are yeah you know because of
tourist cities yeah um if you have to
live in i'm talking you have to live
downtown any major metropolitan where
would you live have you thought about
this if if i had lived
you're gonna live downtown l.a oh no i
don't know new york city that's what we
said in new york but we took new york to
new york city paris take note hey you're
going international dude
rich boy hold on the [ __ ] hold on
uh for maybe grace all right
why don't you go see the new buzz
lightyear and jack off i'm being crazy
uh hold on how about how about miami
miami is not bad i don't live downtown
miami in miami downtown nah nah not me i
could live in brickell in miami kind of
it's just all big buildings
right well think about it but but i was
thinking about i
you know it's not bad certain parts of
idaho the downtown idaho i could
literally oh boise wait we did that
well yeah i guess
i've not been not been well fantastic
yeah cleanest city uh austin's but you
again you'll be downtown austin daddy
like yeah you want to go downtown l.a
boys are too hot first of all too hot
you know what i said and i got roasted
by my uh peers as i said washington i
love washington dc yeah and then jay
goes look up the crime rate in downtown
washington dc he said the white house is
right next to the ghetto correct i was
like all right my bad yeah they were
fighting the big brain on jay
like
the block over yeah next to the white
house and i said boston
but this is the summers i was just in
boston
boston and i was faced with the north
end
and it was [ __ ] amazing gorgeous
italian guys they just hey doing what's
going on oh my god my favorite boston's
great it is a great charleston south
carolina i forgot how great i love
scotland so you know i always do the
wilbur then the problem we do the wilbur
i do two shows of the wilbur i fly and i
j i'm there one night it's a far flight
yeah so i'm like we gotta find a club
because i want to experience the city
because i can experience the city in
three days so we're doing laugh boston
uh in september yep i'm doing live
boston new year's eve i can't yeah can't
wait it was just with uh the owner
can't wait yeah but yeah do you think
about any metric like i'm saying you
guys stay downtown dude you ready for
this we have to look i have to get out
the map phoenix
oh yes
you stay in phoenix well
scottsdale no no
no i don't like downtown phoenix
new york city phoenix got boring well no
new york
hey man one big downtown new york's the
best it's one you can't live in new york
you can't live in new york god damn hold
on hold on hold on connecticut some
people connect you're cool uh downtown
in the town yeah i live downtown
philly's not bad philly's not bad
when the last time i went to philly i
was just there not much dangerous a
little dicey see that's thing you think
about other cities and they're blue city
now
even though they're blue-collar hardcore
what was i seeing vote blue so those
cities that defend the police oh you
want to stay in baltimore downtown
homelessness and and deep on the police
and and
i'm telling you i'm telling you portland
downtown
i was and i can defend myself yeah
unless they have a gun cool bring it on
they don't i mean they do
i was scared walking around yeah first
time ever i was like oh this is unsafe
yeah first time ever
so this you got to look at that map and
say what city's defunded the police
you're not going to live there
you know
but uh charleston uh yeah south carolina
i've always heard great things
oh ready for this nashville
the downtown a little slow but it's kind
of safe
you're gonna deal with [ __ ]
bachelorette parties all the time and
people on the the [ __ ]
bikes drinking whoo
downtown all i know is the answer is not
l.a
it's not not saying san francisco no
it's not san francisco you know what i
said you ready for this san diego i was
about to say san diego
what not bad huh well if i didn't have
to hustle i'd be insane
i'm gonna die in san diego dude that's
where i die really yeah what about 92
i'll pass away and say i have fantasy
in what european city can die in europe
yeah like like what like uh in the south
of italy and like you know or or
something like that on a creek island
santorini you're gonna get out there
early though daddy you don't wanna wake
up yeah you don't wait till you're 90 to
fly out there i just gotta hustle
daddy's still gotta hustle got kids
isn't it where do you think about those
staying a major metropolitan city daddy
better stay relevant until he's 75 or
he's going to be in some dreams yeah
work to do got some work good work got
some work no relaxing gotta age it too
ain't no oh i'll be i'll be a shriveled
prune i will look like
somebody took a piece of jerky and
boiled it twice now i will say this if
if you can stay right outside the
downtown there's not a better i know
this unbiased come from there there's
not a better right outside downtown than
cherry creek now it's right next to the
hometown you are down there is cherry
creek you are wonderful is heaven on
earth it is a great part of the oh
fantastic the housing weather is always
sunny i mean winter's sucked down
denver cherry creek check creek is where
cherry creek north specifically
which means you have reason you are
right in french yeah but i mean new
york's the two we all said we all have
we all said new york but then i was like
no it's too easy to take new york out
there yeah new york's fantastic but you
don't want to stay there
what else you got jen
where would you stay chen
[Music]
uh that's a tough one i don't know
maybe texas
you guys stay in austin downtown austin
just i don't know some part of texas i
just because you do go fishing there
yeah there's like places to go watch
music there's there's a bunch of stuff
dallas is nice
that's i like dallas out of texas cities
dallas is sweet yeah houston's too big
man traffic's too bad money
there we go
post malone
has had a baby girl
and he's gonna be a husband too he's uh
wife enough do we know what his girl has
he talked about his girl
no not at all
he hasn't said her name publicly she's
basically
obsessed with him yeah i'm sure
those face tattoos are so confusing to
me my boy mike stud hangs out with him
saying this boy can drink man yeah
he's gonna stop take care of his health
now more he says he's trying again oh
she's korean holy [ __ ] he just moved up
on chin's list there you go buddy click
on it i can't see which one's which
though i see this
he's pretty
his tattoos are interesting right yeah
man he's got
he's got some crazy and that's his girl
i mean that's all the pictures that are
popping up i don't know who this is
those aren't her tats are they
no she's just just just just just just
just so she broke up with her so i yeah
there must be this crazy scroll down to
the they go to that one
this one yeah
he's a good looking guy man
he's different looking he didn't i think
he looks cool in any interview he's like
the nicest girl sweetest guy yeah i
heard he's great [ __ ] talented yeah
be able to come up to him on the street
like he's
super nice to them true artist he's
beautiful but i just yeah i might get a
little slide through the shirt off but
dude when you have so many tattoos see
that picture which one this one after
playing emergency
same chest genetics i don't think so
let's not say that why would you say
that though i don't know yeah but don't
say that
get away look he's in a tropical anyway
look at his shoulder drinking as much as
he does but he doesn't lift weights
what'd you say if you're drinking
that's a good base to work with you
could get him jacked
yeah if you put on if you lost 15 pounds
yeah he's not bad at 20 pounds of fat
and put on five to 10 pounds of muscle
you would look drastically different
it's just never going to happen he's got
drinking 18 beers a day he's got broad
shoulders he's got big arms you could
work with that dude that's nice that's a
good piece of clothing
his physical almost not a super fan of
possible i love postman my kids love him
he's amazing
again my buddy mike stud is friends with
him and he's like he's the best guy ever
like he's a guy's guy cool and then he
uh
you know he he learned to play the
guitar off guitar hill wow he was really
good at guitar hero someone was like
dude you're a little just a musician
yeah he's just a musician
and he did his yeah
white iverson
mixtape and that bloom the [ __ ] up now
here you go all the face tats in the
world i love a nice face dad dude i'm
obsessed with neck tattoos i wish are
you oh i wish i why i look like a hell's
angel if i do it why are you so dude
there's a the one that i don't say
leader i don't see who it is there's a
proud boy at my show a bunch of proud
voice game jesus tatted up
tatted up so you need help man you let
us know i'm like
i don't know what help i would need but
if i ever do need that help
yeah fandiva but
proud boys
how about last time i was there was
during the riot uh antifun probably
they're on our i mean their leaders
black
they're riding outside my hotel their
sirens
they go down and cop goes don't go
outside man like dude i'm just gonna get
a coffee i'm telling you don't go
outside but i go out antifa and proud
boys and the swat team all got together
the one thing they shared in common bee
shop fans i have a picture of me in
front of the three of them like this
i was the equalizer yeah they were great
yeah i don't know man yeah i
what do the proud boys stand for i don't
even know
what their thing is are they are they
mark you want to dive into western
culture
and then they call it as a result they
call them well the one leader got
arrested the leader is black so they
call them white supremacists yeah i
don't know what they are
yeah gavin say they say far right
extremists but are they um
and that's the thing with a lot of
far-red extremist groups is like you
can't necessarily take them at face
value for how they're presenting
themselves because there's not a lot of
groups out there that go yes we are a
fascist group that's not really deja
yeah they say they're they're far-right
neo-fascist groups wikipedia they down
you ask them they won't it's like if you
ask i don't mean a rapture but if you
ask uh uh hell's angel like oh you guys
do this this they go excuse me we're a
motorcycle club yeah we don't do any of
that yeah
if you ask them they would talk about
things like traditional western values
um
you know
traditional gender roles in
relationships they would talk about the
initiation process is like sort of a
joke like to become a problem you have
to graduate through these steps and
it's just like it's kind of silly and
it's a joke and one of them is like you
have to
list off these words like while we're
punching you in the shoulder
you know to list off a number of serial
names or something so they kind of make
it seem like it's just like a goofy frat
so the group believes that western
culture
what's his name what's his name mcginnis
or mcginnis actually he hears advice
yeah he's a story about how he talked
about how proud boys it was uh it was a
[ __ ] musical and he it was started as
a joke and then co-founder of vice yeah
but then he was like he came out a
supporter of trump and they put a lot of
energy he was on training that's not
that serious
but i
i like i don't think you need to
proclaim these values in order to like
have people magnetized to want to be a
part of something and say that oh you
believe this you believe this you
believe this i'm with these guys
you don't have to make it like official
doctrine of your group
so what's the difference between proud
boys and antifa antiva's like the awoke
left extreme yeah they're there it
stands for anti-fascism and they justify
using violence in order to fight what
they perceive as fascism now define
fascism because that doesn't exist in
america you could argue that certain
leaders have fascist tendencies but that
simply doesn't most people wouldn't be
able to tell you the difference so
what's antifa's agenda like what do they
want to get done
tear down the institutions yeah yeah we
can't have that um
they're both it's both young people it
sounds like you're not young no no no
yeah
in
i would say at least with antiques
you're dealing with very naive people
who believe because you it's predicated
on the idea that
the government
leaders
have gone so far off the rails that
violence is justified to come back i
think both sides justify violence
and i do think that
like it says here proud boys were
extremist conservative alt-lite overtly
islamophobic misogynistic transphobic
anti-immigration
it again it all depends on how you're
looking at that i my guess is the brow
boys have probably attracted a whole
bunch of [ __ ] yeah as has antifa
yeah and if you look at who's actually
doing all the damage it can be people
that are using it as an excuse to if you
were in germany
you would know that like look there's
you would feel justified in trying to
subvert the government with violence
right ethically you have to convince
yourself that that things are pretty bad
in america if you're willing to justify
fighting the government with violence
first rather than through organized
non-peaceful protests yeah
yeah and that's where you lose me is my
guess is if you were to get the
legacy media's
description of the proud boys it
wouldn't so they believe violence is
really effective way to solve problems
that's wikipedia yeah i believe you've
talked to them like no like that's
we don't want it yeah i don't i'm sure
both sides like no that's not what you
want to do man i don't know we'd much
rather i don't you know what
i don't know what the [ __ ] i'm talking
about i don't know yeah that's okay dude
all i know is when i was in portland i
saw the homeboy getting arrested i drove
by it all right now anybody else i
didn't film that
college so i'm not joining any other
group so yeah no no but yeah i don't
think proud boys are drinking [ __ ]
white clothes like frat boys you know
that's why i didn't rush for a frat
they're drinking those
i don't know how it works i don't know
how you get in
one thing would be hierarchy versus like
egalitarianism because anytime you have
an extreme right movement like fascist
movements during world war ii it's all
predicated on like we're at the top or
why are you at the top because we have
blue eyes or whatever so violence comes
from that because to enforce a hierarchy
that's arbitrary like you know blonde
hair blue eyes people at the top it's
like well
you can only suppress people like that
so it's division so the left does
something really interesting they go
authority yeah is oppressive
well no
authority can also be protective my
father when i was growing up was my
authority my father was a good father i
was lucky to have a good father so my
father was also my protector and my
provider and my guide so authority is
not always tyrannical patriarch the
patriarch is not always like you know
your boss the patriarchy god as the
father in our in our culture is the idea
that you this is a he's a he's a guide
like your father if he's a good father
we all know what a good father is your
good father is a guide well they set an
example they're leaders it's like an
example business owner like oh you're
just there for these reasons like well
no but that's why i inspire other people
to do better things everybody here
believes in a hierarchy of competence i
don't want people at the top of the
of the authority pyramid just because
they were oppressed in the past that
doesn't make sense because that because
the only way to do it is then then the
only way to divide create those
divisions is through division yeah you
got to be like well you were [ __ ] at
me so i'm going to put myself on top and
then i'm going to do exactly to you what
you did to me which i don't think is
right and if you do that if you start
doing that and then you start and what
you'll do is you want to create identity
politics you're going to get people that
create their own identities and you will
get these white supremacists and you
will get people like right arbitrary
yeah they get violent you know they pick
up a gun and they they they form a gang
and they don't want that the left sees
if you can frame something as an
authority is illegitimate then antifa
makes sense yeah but there are so
there's a wide angle
karl marx right who created communism
why did he hate religion so much why
because in christianity the idea that if
you are if you are suffering if things
aren't as good in this life in
christianity there is meaning and
suffering there's nobility suffering
there's something about suffering well
there's something about suffering but
still loving sacrificing for people
well the problem sweet mark said mark
said no way because that won't that will
not foster revolution you have to take
religion away from the people so people
get so mad that they're like [ __ ] this
there's no afterlife i want mine now and
then they tear down the institutions i'm
kind of on board with this yeah
okay keep going so if you think about if
you listen to like the black lives
matter the the creators of black man
they were all trained marxists if you
listen to them they were anti-family and
in many ways they're anti-church and
how's that going for them right and the
idea was that they're that these are
revolutionary groups sure if you look at
the critical race theorists what they
never talk about and i've read them is
that the system itself is what racist so
if you are a participant in the system
even if you're black you're racist
because you're making money off a racist
system i don't agree with that but
that's what they would do so what is the
what is the what do you want to do get
rid of that you got to get rid of the
system you got to tear down all the
institutions that's where defund the
police comes from and how's that worked
out yeah you've got to remember where
these where this ideology comes yeah
mark yeah mark's no martial i'm calling
marksman yeah i'm blocking marks all
right what does sketching a wig he's not
even wearing real hair [ __ ] this yeah
um i don't know let's see oh no not that
one okay this is it's too long this is
wild yeah but apparently this australian
guy he was in a fight with this
kangaroo for over six minutes why it's
how long it just came out of nowhere and
tried to tackle him his dogs were both
kangaroo tried fighting them yeah
you'll see some of it here the roux
cliff uh my dogs were barking and oh he
comes back for more yeah yeah tell us he
luckily grabbed a stick right there no
that guy hit a fight my dogs were
barking there's the guy he got beat up
yep
he's getting kicked or what
kick and bit six foot buck roux in a bad
mood trying to rip my little dogs out of
the yard
and um oh he took the kangaroo down
oh he's in mouth
they just repeat this video over and
over again
just put it i wanna when he well after
he took him now he punched him in his
stupid nose b what do you think you
could take a kangaroo oh yeah beat the
shot of that king you could right yeah
i'm double-edging that stupid piece of
[ __ ] are you i don't know careful of
that bubba no if this guy can do it look
at him that's his injuries okay not bad
not bad
he's
dude i'm getting mount and i'm [ __ ]
head arm choking that stupid roo
and i'm ground by i'm i'm kicking his
heel and wake up [ __ ] wake up ain't
done no you're not beating him you choke
out a roof for sure oh yeah 100 had an
arm and he'll get your head on
his arms are kind of like like a t-rex
almost yeah you got to get oh i got a
fact for you [ __ ] yeah i want to hear
it yeah dude
you know i did this really in classical
music and read history dude i'm getting
older i like it but i was love you but i
i turned on the tv and there was a kids
channel on there when i missed my kids i
watched kid shows yeah and they had this
guy on there talking about dinosaurs
because the new dress sparks coming out
mm-hmm they had an expert on that hold
on quiz me let's see if i know you're
ready you're ready let me see if i know
it you ready yeah
so as they're talking
a real velociraptor from the movie comes
out the robot the like
and the host which is lester holt who
don't have a top lip he goes
lester holtz goes um
so
you have to throw that i'm sorry lester
holder you got lester holtz right here
nope he has no no top lip yeah it's
weird god went no lip for you let's
figure the bottom one out so
lester holt is interviewing this guy and
the velociraptor comes out and it's huge
right and no top lip and that's fine so
lester holtz goes
is that he's all bottom lip dude lester
holtz goes is the was the velociraptor
that thing's terrifying were they that
size and guy go this can hurt people's
feelings he goes the hollywood made him
this scary he was a real life
velociraptor back in the day was the
size of a small poodle i don't believe
that swear to god i think you're lying
all right bring it up
how big i believe velociraptors were the
size of [ __ ] uh f-15s
besides a small poodle and he goes that
he goes but they were smart but they
made them big you know go up to 100
pounds so who told you 100 pounds is
still small though bro
that's a dog
left them
look how big is velociraptor in real
life click on that gin
roughly the size of a turkey there you
go
shut up
huh yeah dude did you know that bet you
missed that didn't you look how small
they were so here's my thing those
velociraptors i'm punting the [ __ ] out
of stupid things there's a tiny little
yeah they're tiny you ready for this bee
yeah so he goes in the movie two they
jump in a jeep and they're driving
whatever 60 miles an hour and the t-rex
is keeping up with him he goes could a
t-rex really chase down the car he goes
sauce gonna hurt people's feeling that's
hollywood he was so t-rex they were so
big and large and weighed so much
at his max speed which was maybe about
two seconds he goes 10 miles an hour
come on so when i heard that i went not
scared of him anymore i'll run in a
zigzag way and ostrich runs 45 miles an
hour well they're tiny and they have
those stupid little legs
t-rex is
you know heavier than elephant
also he goes so when that thing yells
out the infamous
they don't yell like that it was
actually a high pitch
it was kind of a [ __ ] noise
all right bring up [ __ ] pterodactyl
because i don't like this [ __ ] this is a
doctors are cool this podcast is already
getting shitty
pterodactyl isn't that interesting
though yeah it is size of a small poodle
dude
yeah i want the [ __ ] size and i'm
gonna say it's huge well no one's
debating that
that's big
whoa
wingspan 36 feet holy thing's gonna pick
you up and [ __ ] what
dude 36 feet
that that would kill you
uh almost as long as the hollywood sign
i would [ __ ] oh my god
insane yeah cool
oh you're you're gonna get taken and
eaten that thing is 18 feet high dude i
would [ __ ] my pants as tall as a large
bull draft dude oh that too i would
change get my pants they can fly it'd be
clean though after watching that
postmate thing i'd eat a clean diet and
[ __ ] smooth you're right what is the
weight of that
i would be 550 pounds i'd be his amber
heard dude oh my god a [ __ ] in his nest
dude
we'd be [ __ ]
but back to the velociraptors i'm just
gonna kick him in the stupid faces you
are so easy yeah you're right yeah yeah
that's
you don't dress park that at the one way
yeah and spit out the guy from seinfeld
yeah
fake dinosaur those never existed really
yeah dude
but pterodactyl the more you know hey
you're stuck on pterodactyl still huh
the thing is about that weird dinosaur
yeah not real hey hollywood but terribly
[ __ ] fly and kill us why'd they go
extinct that's [ __ ] crazy to be able
to fly that an animal that big flying i
don't know if that's true but i guess it
is it's on the internet 36 feet
like the hollywood sign i got something
else for you you're still stuck on
pterodactyls let's try and get you off
of that you know abraham lincoln yeah
65. six five sure probably a pretty good
basketball player i dunk on putting my
nuts on stupid beard but listen to this
you know he had a high-pitched voice
how do you know that that's what they
say
yeah uh they they said they said in the
stories that they have it was
yeah that's what they said because even
um when homeboy played him in that movie
uh lincoln yeah what's his name uh
daniel day-lewis yeah he did that voice
but he said in his in his findings he
had a much higher voice bring him up
look at the pictures of him of of
abraham yeah i think he died when he was
ever heard of him like 56.
or nobody
of lincoln he was he had a very austere
six four and they said he had a
high-pitched voice he look at it but
just bring him up right there look at
his face look at how old you know
look how big he was dude now he's now
he's my size so yeah i would tell the
drawing hey can you make me smaller now
look at that face for a sec yeah that's
an old face never similar to yours
died forty-something back then think
about maybe 50.
like that's weathered like there get
that picture right there that outfit is
[ __ ] lit dude you know what you know
that the one recording they have it's
him going hey
[Laughter]
your move disney dude
here's all [ __ ] up i know guess what
slaves y'all free
down there that little one next to the
tent
why is this hair [ __ ] up next to the
tent no right next one over to the right
one over right nope to the right yeah
right there let me see this one yeah
look at that face
weather dude
we know his son died you know he had a
kid died oh he had more than that so
he's very i think three of his children
hey you want a very underrated movie so
underrated so [ __ ] good abraham
lincoln vampire slayer oh yeah
we're reading this script
fantastic yeah really oh
they're supposed to do george
washington's vampire slayer but i don't
know what happened i am such a fan of
that show how old was he when he died
because that's crazy
damn man
that's long back then yeah
he's born in kentucky
yep
a log cabin he's a march baby
a strong man he got shot
yeah
go to jiu jitsu oh he was assassinated
yeah you didn't know that for some
reason i thought he survived the shot
and then survived and then died no my
booth
john wilkes booth that was tupac theater
some reason i survived that oh it was
the back head oh in the movies it's
always in the front yeah john john
wilkes i'm in the back huh back to the
head yep
after the war
wow he went to the
mary todd his wife had lost three of her
children and then and and lost three of
her children to fever
uh one at ten the other at four i mean
really awful awful and then she went
they went to the theater and she he
he was killed right in front of her and
then she spent the rest of her life in a
mental institution poor thing think
about the pain she went through
three children and they weren't babies
when they died now they died of fevers
yeah the one was like four or five yeah
yeah and then and then her oldest one
died which was too much and then her
husband and so she wasn't a shame yeah
she used to talk to them it makes me
want to cry it really does go and cry
over it really doesn't mean
it makes me cry over 1862 dude i know
and she lived 150 years ago and it still
makes me want to cry some people suffer
so badly man
anyway some people are doing that right
now
right i think you're crying over the
proud boy still no
yeah you're [ __ ] fascist
yeah dude no i know what's going on here
you
know
amber heard
shout out to pterodactyls is that a chin
that's pretty much it you have a long
podcast buddy i feel like we covered a
lot we've been going longer hopefully
that information helped you guys on the
dinosaurs
don't be scared of velociraptors i'm not
i told my son that because he is scared
of him you're going for oh no you're not
oh you got a little time i'm in l.a do i
daddy has some time off thank god daddy
needs it me too because summer is a
weird time to tour so san francisco is
going to be rescheduled i'll have dates
announced soon for that i'll be around
la doing spots i'm at the laugh factory
on thursday i think i'm uh improv friday
saturday but the next big show shop and
friends is next wednesday june 22nd be
if you're in town please jump on board
that is june 22nd shopping friends me
and some monsters at the hollywood
improv at 8pm and the trash panda summer
tour continues in fort wayne indiana
july 14-16
downtown san diego in the heart of san
diego at the laugh factory in san diego
july 21st through the 23rd
baltimore is august 4th 26th magooby's
uh august 4th through the 6th appleton
wisconsin september 8th through the 10th
that just got added and we have houston
in boston but uh next up is fort wayne
indiana and san diego for the trash
panda tour the tea i'm wearing now can
only get in person on tour
uh milwaukee improv july 21
he has a lot of time off yeah and then
cap cities july 28 to the 30th we get
those all three all four those are good
markets yeah those are good hopefully
cap city is open i know i've had their
problems yeah i told you that hard to do
but all right kids that's it we love you
guys this the final kid we're out